the division is an online loot driven
RPG cleverly disguised as the
third-person shooter set in the grim
aftermath of a biological attack on New
York City admirably the game commits to
its grounded vision of a
medically-induced apocalypse and while
its story sticks primarily to tried and
true survival tropes the narrative is
solidly executed key moments received
full cutscenes and in-between constant
radio banter means you always know
exactly what you're doing and why that
alone goes a long way towards making
your actions feel meaningful plus it's
desolate haunting recreation in midtown
Manhattan might be the most impressive
urban world map outside of a rockstar
game with dense urban environments that
seem painstakingly assembled rather than
cut and paste it into place the variety
and authenticity of the world invite
exploration just like the streets of San
Andreas sadly the predictable AI isn't
quite as impressive no matter who you're
up against you know exactly how each
enemy is going to come at you which can
make certain lower stakes gunfights feel
like a chore some of the basic gameplay
mechanics are slightly sloppy as well
the core aiming and shooting are totally
serviceable but you can't Crouch jump or
go prone and I occasionally had to
contend with objects like poorly placed
railings obstructing my view when I was
a new cover though some of the divisions
we can't extempore others work extremely
well being able to equip any unlocked
perk on the fly for example turns the
game's extensive skill trees into
flexible strategic options the active
abilities in particular which include
seeker Minds deployable cover and a
portable health station had a
distinctive signature to the moments
moment shooting as a result the
divisions gameplay is generally fun and
engaging in spite of the enemy AI sure
they're predictable but when they're
rushing you and sniping you and trying
to blow you up all at once you still
have to dodge aim heal and get back into
cover regardless
the action is always frantic and
challenging and while that can make the
experience exhausting it can also and
frequently does trigger real adrenaline
unfortunately the adrenaline rush
occasionally slows to a drip at least
for a time most side missions are
recycled throughout the game and
eventually feel repetitive especially
since you're forced to grind through
them in an attempt to level up your
character thankfully the larger campaign
missions deliver an impressive variety
of thrilling scenarios and carefully
crafted environments I experienced a
healthy number of memorable gameplay
moments and intense boss battles and
impressively you can walk right into
these missions from the hub world with
zero loading the division also offers
four player co-op throughout but
importantly it remains fun even when
you're flying solo if you can pull
together a full four-man team though the
gameplay blossoms in unexpected ways
when you're able to revive downed
teammates cover multiple sight lines set
up planks and utilise a wider set of
character perks you realize both the
level design and the enemy AI almost
function better during the massive
firefights in - not only does the
gameplay become far more strategic you
finally feel truly unstoppable if you're
feeling a little less cooperative you
can also visit the dark zone a massive
unstructured PvP area in the middle of
the city where other players might help
you conquer the AI or they might
backstab you and steal all the stuff
you've collected the tension of not
knowing how an interaction will play out
is truly unlike anything you'll find in
a modern shooter and the significance of
loot back in the main game makes the
stakes in the dark zone feel incredibly
real to be clear loot is an integral
part of the experience your chances of
survival are heavily dictated by the
gear you equip so be prepared to spend
plenty of time in menus comparing the
numerical attributes of kneepads and
pistol holsters that may sound dry to
some but honestly Luke compelled me to
keep playing more than any other aspect
the division is relentless making you
earn every kill so when you stumble upon
a new weapon with drastically increased
stats you feel like sudden surge of
elation because you know you might
finally have an edge over your damage
soaking enemies I only wish those
moments had cropped up more often put
simply the division is stingy when it
comes to gear and XP it still manages to
feel plenty of rewarding as you progress
but a slightly kinder XP system and an
extra layer of gear rarity may have gone
a long way to alleviate the frustration
and fatigue
experience still no matter how
frustrated I grew with the game's
tiresome enemies or its demanding
leveling structure I absolutely could
not stop playing the world was too
engrossing the loot was too enticing and
the campaign was too gripping for me to
simply walk away in fact I'm gonna go
start grinding for the high-end endgame
gear right now I bind up a problem
yes good work